play the game a little bit and leave us
feedback in the beta forums or if you
get the survey yeah and go to the link
give it a give the game a chance and we
spend a lot of time iterating it and
balancing everything so we'd really like
you to hammer at it let's see that's at
the low-tide shows
so we were asking what or what does not
carry over from data into the final
multi player a game oh nothing yeah the
beta's always helped campaign and that's
part of it because we're still
developing a lot of like we'll be
iterating on the feedback that we got so
things will be changing so trying to
carry some that stuff over wouldn't
really apply later later on
yeah I was awesome oh oh oh that car
exploded I think we've actually just
recently reduced the radius on that a
little large so but it likes to use his
revived pack instead of doing our normal
arrive so that he can keep fighting
while he's reviving his teammates yes
that's one of his tactics which is
awesome so Madagascar City is one of our
maps that tries to facilitate a little
more long-range combat so I'm interested
in seeing venecia roles with the
shabbiha the beta last the December 13th
someone was asking it if they'll be
headshot indicator so when you kill
someone on the right side I'll indicate
if you've managed to get them with a
headshot as well so again the beta yeah
it's answered already there but the beta
runs from December 4th to the 13th yeah
they're definitely our headshot
indicators in the game both when you're
doing a headshot on a player and then
also when you get down by a headshot we
tell you in the kill card
really like these towers that one of
those I made this map Rodney create some
cool verticality give you some rope
options Oh Millie
oh and I got killed by every year do you
go no Rodney Axelrod it's gonna buy my
interest eternity yes let's wreck some
fools here all right
oh [ __ ] well someone asked that the
spawns are random which they're not
obviously we're placing people we're
supplying teammates together
no it's yeah absolutely I know that the
spawn point the spawn systems been
something that we've no doubt looked at
quite a bit to facilitate what we're
trying to do by creating fronts and such
and so the spawn system is not random it
actually takes a wide variety of things
into account so people ask about metals
and there's one that just popped up a
second ago correct the the metal is in
the beta is a little light compared to
previously uncharted games but it's a
betas we're ship will have a wide
variety of more metals present its you
players doing a lot of revives and you
might think that's you know just for the
stream but actually we do this all the
time when we're playing because it's
actually the most effective way of play
the game is to keep your team alive
absolutely and most high-level players
they're reviving constantly we've seen
from our best QA guys to use the chin to
my stone like the moment of players down
there trying to revive them instantly
with the edge into my just super
effective but also costly and you can
only use it and you know number of times
before even out of cash I'm gonna follow
my hunter here he's gonna seek out
targets for me
so we keep getting a lot of questions
that just keep reiterating that we
haven't revealed all of the modes and
all the options for the beta again the
beta is going to be just a limited look
at what goes into the final version of
multi-player we'll be revealing a lot
more of that once we're closer to launch
how's the change of events okay
Eldorado trying to crawl down my
teammate here I hit my make it good nice
nice job so that was a great example of
how the hunter it can be taken out by an
effective team yeah the sidekicks
generally are less effective when when
you're having a team really sort of
coordinate themselves around taking them
out they look like they were focused
firing from a distance on the hunter as
she's approaching so it wasn't able to
get a grab there so there's there's only
two maps in the beta but we're watching
with eight if you missed it you almost
got a sneaky sneak preview of a third
map that we have down someone else 100
here so we have a handy a quick weapons
swap that we put in an l2 square it's
really useful for these kind of load
outs we have close range and long range
combined gonna try to come over to my
teammate here oh yeah should have fell
off great like here somewhere yeah one
of the great things to do when you're in
the down stays actually just move to
some cover allows you can only be
protected those your allies as they come
in for the revive oh that's just so nice
so was it asking if you can take
multiple sidekicks so that's something
that is possible absolutely in your
in-game story you're gonna clip up to
three sidekicks if you want to the only
kids that you can't spawn more than one
at a time you have that limit yeah if
you have a sidekick
alive and you spawn to do and it will
kill your current sidekick it's that
close match yeah this is a really close
match some people asking about the
controller customization options in
terms of which triggers you can use and
the fat type of stuff is being switched
I know in our single-player that we were
investigating a lot of times we were
talking about that go do it do it
unless you get them missed that was the
controller customization options aren't
as rich as we want them quite yet but
for those who are interested I know
there are a few of whom we do have
currently have the option to save your
shoulder swap there's also the l1 like
lr1 swapped with like Alto r2 I think
that make thought that was in there no
no we should look at this it's
definitely something that we're
considering if it's not in the beta it's
definitely yeah absolutely we're really
trying to put in a lot of controller
customization options and releases their
feedback from previous games and sapote
c4 especially things like the shoulder
swap yeah 15 health left
like I disabled the controller swapper
we're talking about this yesterday
because I'm really hard on the artifacts
all right this is a really close match
it's pretty good we've seen games like
this turned around though or we're up 33
29 and then the other team wins oh my
god
all right last kill let's kill nice was
a good match to end on that was a very
good match to end all really good
you